today on the Matt Walsh show we're told
that all white people in the country are
the beneficiaries of privilege but I
have some examples of white people that
would appear to have no privilege at all
of any kind and and I think that's
because our notion of privilege this
idea of white privilege is far too
simplistic and literally too black and
white so we'll talk about that also five
headlines and then today in our daily
cancellation I will cancel the mayor of
Oakland for claiming that a swing in a
public park is a hate crime somebody put
up a swing in a public park and is now
being accused of committing a hate crime
and it gets even more ridiculous than
that so you have to stick around for
that but here's something we'll start
with this here's something you probably
didn't hear about a few months ago a
region of our country was gripped by a
natural disaster devastated by it that
region is Eastern Kentucky it was
flooded entire neighborhoods towns
underwater here's some footage from whas
at Kentucky as you can see there I mean
it looks biblical everything underwater
right
and you never heard about this did you
and that's not your fault
if you don't live in the area if you
don't live in Kentucky the national
media doesn't talk about it then how are
you gonna hear about it here's an
account from one man a trailer park
resident who lost everything in the
floods and here's here's what he has to
say listen I walked outside and saw
everything that was already up and I
knew it had to be deep already up to my
knees at least and I came through the
house and told my wife you know don't
freak out but we gotta get out here
right now we gotta get kids out and I
carried two kids in the van got her in
the van drove over there and I was
freaking out I didn't know what to do
only thing I could do is just try to run
over here and grab anything that I
thought was sentimental
possibly couldn't buy back lost
everything everything it took us years
to build it's gone one night one day
rebuild try to find someone safe my kids
don't have to go through that again
start off small make it back somehow now
why why didn't you hear about this well
because it's Eastern Kentucky this is
happening mostly to poor white people in
trailer parks and the media simply
doesn't care about poor white people in
trailer parks and when I say poor you
know I mean poor I think the word poor
almost doesn't quite capture the
situation for many people that live in
that part of the country
now as I tell you about Eastern Kentucky
I'm gonna put up on screen on the screen
some pictures taken by Shelby Lee Adams
a photographer these were published in
an article in NPR a few years ago these
are not pictures from the 19th century
this is life in Eastern Kentucky today
nine of the poorest counties in the
entire nation
nine of them are in one in this one
little small part of the country used to
Kentucky the poverty rate in one County
Osley County is 45% that's nearly half
nearly half of the residents are in
poverty across the entire Appalachian
region the poverty rate is almost 20
percent the average income is is 37,000
across the entirety in Eastern Kentucky
it's thirty thousand that's sixteen
thousand dollars less than the average
income nationally in 2014 the new york
times magazine tried to compile a list
of the places in the in the country with
the worst quality of life and according
to this calculation the worst place in
the country to live the worst quality of
life in the entire country is eastern
kentucky let me read from their article
this is a published of New York
times.com from their magazine it says
the team at the upshot at times news and
data analyst venture compiled six basic
metrics to give a
sure of the quality and longevity of
life in each county of the nation
educational attainment household income
jobless rate disability rate life
expectancy at obesity rate waiting each
equally six counties in Eastern
Kentucky's coal count country ranked
among the bottom 10 Clay County and dead
last might as well be in a different
country the median household income
there is barely above the poverty line
at $22,000
so he's twenty-two thousand two hundred
ninety six dollars that's the median
income and is just over half the
nationwide medium only seven point four
percent of the population has a
bachelor's degree or higher the
unemployment rate is twelve point seven
percent the disability rate is nearly as
high at eleven point seven percent
nationwide the figure is one point three
percent life expectancy is six years
shorter than average perhaps related
nearly half of Clay County is obese
later on the article it says despite
this rural poverty is largely shunted
aside in the conversation about
inequality much in the way that rural
areas have been left behind by broader
shifts in the economy the sheer
intractability of rural poverty raises
uncomfortable questions about how to fix
it or to what extent it is even fixable
now I should mention the suicide rate in
Appalachia is 17 percent higher than the
national average which is not surprising
given everything that I just read and
then of course here's the one thing that
you probably have heard about Eastern
Kentucky in the Appalachian region
generally is that it's beset by drug
addiction particularly opioid addiction
addiction the opioid crisis has hit this
part of the country perhaps harder than
anywhere else now why do I bring all
this up because I have a question for
you and I something to consider take a
hypothetical person living in Clay
County Kentucky apparently you know
perhaps the worst place in the country
to live Clay County Kentucky and let's
say a child a white child living in a
trailer park in Clay County
father committed suicide years ago
mother's addicted to painkillers
household income is $18,000 a year in a
good year he lives in a two
bedroom trailer in a low-lying area
susceptible to flooding according to New
York Times magazine he has he has maybe
the worst quality of life of anyone
anywhere else in the country now this is
a hypothetical example but it represents
the situation that a great many children
in that part of the country are in
there's nothing there's nothing absurd
about about the this hypothetical it's
not far-fetched by any means and now the
question in what sense in what possible
sense and what specific sense could we
say that this child is privileged you
know we hear a lot about white privilege
we hear that all white people everywhere
in the country are the beneficiaries of
this privilege and yet when we look at
the reality okay when we look into to
borrow a phrase from from the from let
from the left when we look at the lived
experiences of so many white people in
the country this privilege doesn't seem
to amount to very much at all so again
where does the privilege come in for
this child when does he get to cash it
in in what particular moment of his life
can we say oh that happened because of
white privilege what kind of her what do
you mean wet what what sort of privilege
is this he's dirt poor so it's not
economic privilege um he doesn't have
access to a good education so it's not
an educational sort of privilege he
doesn't have good health care so it's
not health care privilege
there's no privilege in any of those
senses what about systemically does the
system favor him I think this is in fact
what we what we will be told we will be
told that okay yeah I mean he doesn't
have economic privilege doesn't have
educational privilege he doesn't have a
privilege in terms of his health but but
he's got systemic privilege really do
you think the
some favors this child that we're
talking about I mean whatever system
what we're talking about whatever system
were referring to here it would seem to
me that all of the systems have
forgotten about this child and everybody
else living in that part of the country
there is just no sense in which you can
say that a poor white kid in a trailer
in Appalachia is favored by the system
there is no system no system anywhere
that favors him he is forgotten by every
system do you think when he walks into a
job interview one day if that day ever
arrives for him which very likely it
won't but you think if he does as a poor
Kentucky kid with a thick accent you
know living in poverty all his life do
you think his resume is gonna go to the
top of the sack do you think he's not
gonna suffer any discrimination any
negative assumptions given his
background his economic his economic
status his accent his mannerisms and so
on what employers are going to favor
hiring people out of trailer parks it
would seem like none of them do because
if they did there wouldn't be trailer
parks because all those people would
have jobs and good jobs by now the claim
of white privilege just doesn't hold up
to the reality that many white people
experience and live through and in fact
I would I would argue that the very
concept of white privilege the very
claim of white privilege is proof that
white privilege doesn't exist because
the only way you can claim it is if you
have completely forgotten about and
discounted the millions of dirt poor
white people forgotten by the system
across the country that's the only way
that this the whole notion of white
privilege when you hear white privilege
your mind immediately comes to you know
relatively well-off white people living
in the suburbs that's what you think of
as the sort of the picture of white
privilege and so we have a race to
borrow another popular term from the
left we have erased all of the white
people who don't fit into that just they
don't count
gotten about them and for this
hypothetical child who is not really
hypothetical because millions of kids
are in this position for this child and
for the people there that's what they're
used to they're worse they're used to
being forgotten they've been forgotten
by every single system there is no
system no system that is saying let's go
to those people and help them out this
is why our discussion of privilege is
too simplistic
it is literally black and white which is
absurd it doesn't work with the reality
and this is when we get into the you
know the back and forth of anecdotes and
so somebody will respond by talking
about a black child growing up in the
inner city and the the struggles and
hardships he faces struggles and
hardships which are immense of course
and just like the white child in the
trailer park
these are struggles and hardships that
for many people are insurmountable but
the problem is we could go back and
forth with anecdotes all day long you
give me one I give you one literally of
millions of examples on both sides maybe
maybe that that's a good signal that
it's worth thinking about this topic of
privilege all wrong because I you know I
personally would not want to go up to
someone living in one of those trailer
parks which is now water damaged because
of flooding that nobody cared about I
would want to go up to someone like that
and tell them about their privilege
that's not that's not something I would
want to do I don't know about you so I
think it's time to expand our notion of
privilege and you here because I'm not
saying that privilege is not exist I'm
not saying that privilege is a myth I
think white privilege is a myth
privilege though is not there is
something called privilege there are
there are people who are privileged but
what does what is privilege I mean how
do you get privilege who are the
privileged people in this country I
think that that we could
we could think of privilege in two broad
categories so there's economic privilege
we could say that someone who's born in
a well-off family a well-off community
is privileged in many different ways you
know they're gonna they're gonna get the
best of everything in terms of luxuries
and necessities and they're gonna
probably have good schools and they're
gonna have good health care and they're
gonna have access to whatever they want
that's privileged of course but we
already have established that not every
what to put it mildly this is an
understatement
not every white person is economically
privileged a great many of them are not
so that is not something that can be
separated by race but then there's a
deeper sense I think there's a deeper
sense of privilege the sense in which I
would say that I am privileged I mean I
wasn't born to a well-off family or
which I wasn't born endured poverty
either so I suppose I did I am the
beneficiary of some kind of economic
privilege just to be born in the middle
class there's a lot better than being
born in a trailer park are being born in
the in in the inner city economically
speaking but I tell you the real
privilege that I had okay the real
privileges I had in modern society is
that I was born to of household with two
parents who were both living both in the
home married stay married stayed married
throughout my entire childhood and are
still married today by the way cared
about my well-being cared about my
education and cared about my moral
formation as a person that is I think
the real privilege that I inherited and
I think that's what privilege really is
for most people if you have that if you
if you have it you have if you have that
going for you then you're gonna probably
get a fair shake at life and there are
plenty of people in trailer parks in
Eastern Kentucky or in the inner city
who have that but a great many don't if
you look at the fatherless rate the rate
of broken homes and domestic violence
and and domestic turmoil in the inner
city and in
poor trailer park areas in the
Appalachia region they're gonna find
that those rates are very high much
higher than they are for a lot of us and
that doesn't that doesn't explain
everything I mean if you if you are born
to a two-parent household with parents
that love you and care about you and you
live in dirt poverty you're still gonna
have a lot of challenges and there's a
very good chance that you're gonna be
you're gonna be in that dirt poverty for
your entire life because it's gonna be a
very hard obstacle to get over even then
but even so that is a that is a great
advantage that's a great leg up for any
kid now it's kind of sad that these days
we have to talk about this as being a
privilege because this should not be a
privilege it should this is natural this
is how it should be for everybody this
should be a given but that's not the
case and we know that the the rates of
broken homes and and and fatherless
homes are high and getting higher for
communities across the country in the
black community it's you know seventy
percent about the seventy percent of
black kids in the inner-city it's even
higher grow up without fathers in the
home for white people the rate is lower
but it's much higher than it should be
and it's getting higher that's what we
should be focusing on if we're really if
we're really if we really want to talk
about privilege I think these are the
two areas we should be looking at and we
shouldn't be looking at them because we
want to punish the people who have that
kind of someone who has the privilege of
the economic privilege or the privilege
or the the much better privilege much
deeper privilege of being born to a you
know two-parent household with loving
parents it's not like we're looking to
punish them or take anything away from
them to even the score that's not the
right way of approaching this it's to
look at the the kids who don't have that
and figure out what can we do for them
so that they do have it I think that's
how our discussion of privilege should
work we're gonna move on now to
headlines number one and here's a thing
that no one could have seen seen coming
well no one could have seen it coming
except for
you know people with brain cells people
with brain cells did see this coming
protestors that would be read felons
pulled down a statue of George
Washington in Portland last night here's
the here's the footage of that yes
nobody could have seen this coming
nobody at all except like I said people
with brains because this was inevitable
some of us like yours truly years ago
were warning that tearing down the
Confederate statues allowing a mob to
tear them down or tearing them down at
the behest of the mob would lead to this
it was always gonna lead to this and yet
a lot of dumb weak spineless
conservatives said no no that's not
gonna happen you know three four years
ago when they were going around tearing
down all the statues there were even
good a lot of conservatives were saying
yeah this is time it's time to take them
down the left will stop here I'm sure
they'll stop and they'll be satisfied
and we'll get rid of the Confederate
statue then they're not gonna cross any
other lines after that these people will
never learn they'll just never learn the
mob does not stop the left doesn't stop
never gonna be satisfied it's not hard
to see how one leads to another that's
the very frustrating thing is that you
didn't have to be a prophet to prophesy
into the future you'd have to look into
a crystal ball to know that this was
gonna happen it's it's it's it's it's a
it's not hard to see it the Confederates
were slave owning society the founders
were slave owning society there are just
there are ways to distinguish the two
there are distinctions you can make of
course between the two groups but the
mob doesn't do nuance and that's why
I've been saying all along you even if
you don't like a particular statue and
you think that yeah I'd be better if
that statute didn't exist yeah I'd be
better if that if we could take that
statute down we don't take it down now
in this circumstance in this situation
at the behest of the the raging mob
because it sends the wrong message it's
the wrong symbolism and it's not a
thoughtful act taking down a monument
that is stood for a hundred years or
more I
a priceless piece of art taking that
down should be a thoughtful act and
everybody should understand why we're
doing this if it needs to be done at all
but this is not thoughtful it's mindless
and simplistic so we take down the the
statues what do they say when they're
taken down robert e lee's statute or
jefferson davis what are we here we here
these were racist they were slave owners
you know or they were traitors those are
the three things we hear racist slave
owner trader okay well if that's the
standard now for tearing down a statue
then a lot of other statues are coming
down arguably all of them certainly for
racist as I've talked about many times
over the last couple weeks everybody in
the 19th century was racist by our
standards today everybody by our
standards racist and certainly before
that I want to go back to Columbus 500
years ago yeah everybody was it was
horrible bigots by our standards today
so all the statues are coming down slave
owners their slave owners all over the
world and if not slave owners people who
were fine with slavery
you know either supported it or just had
no problem with it didn't question it
traitor
well George Washington was the traitor
of the British crown if the
Revolutionary War had gone the other way
they would have been hung as traitors if
that's the standard those statues are
going down and it's not gonna stop here
either I mean I think we see now all the
statues are coming down all of our
historical heroes and icons all of them
number two here's the CEO of chick-fil-a
Dan Cathy doing what you just have to
see yourself watch I know we're starting
to giving some of our closing moments
here but a story that was shared with me
by a dear friend who shared with me
about a revival that was taking place in
a church in Texas and at that revival in
the front seat was an older
african-american young over African
American
can men man they're sitting there and
this young man got up that was there in
that service and he'd been so gripped
with conviction about the racism that
was in that local community and a small
town in Texas that he took a shoe brush
and he walked over to this elderly
gentleman and he knelt on his knees and
began to shine his shoes and tears began
to flow and that service it was an
attitude of conviction so I invite folks
just to put some words to action here
and if we need to find somebody that
needs to have this shoe shine we need to
just go right on over and shine their
shoes and whether they got tennis shoes
are owned or not maybe they got sandals
own it really doesn't matter but there's
a time which we need to have you know
some some personal action here and they
would need to give a hug and some system
and some stock in chick-fil-a I bought
about 1500 of these and I gave it all
our chick-fil-a operators and staff
number of years ago and so in
expressions of a contrite heart of a
sense of humility a sense of shame a
sense of embarrassment begin with an
apologetic heart I think that's what our
world needs to hear today I'll tell you
what Dan here's my here's my alternative
suggestion how about I don't shine
anybody's shoes or bow to anyone or
kneel to anyone or apologize to anyone
for things I didn't do because I have no
remorse and I have no guilt and I have
no shame and I have no embarrassment for
historical racism or slavery and you
know why because I had nothing to do
with any of that and that's not some
sort of technicality okay I'm not being
pedantic here by saying well technically
I had nothing to do with it I didn't I
didn't exist I didn't exist when those
things were happening how could I
possibly be responsible and
ancestors were in Ireland in fact and
they didn't have such a great life
either historically they were persecuted
by the British are any Brits gonna shine
my shoes and then they came here and
they were discriminated against to the
Irish people
my ancestors historically have not had a
had had a good time of it many other
groups could be you could say the same
about so what am I supposed to be sorry
for
my ancestors were busy dying in the
potato famine while people were buying
slaves in this country they weren't
slave owners I literally cannot
apologize for it it wouldn't make any
sense for me to do and I'm not going to
do something that's incoherent and makes
no sense
just because the emotional mob has
demanded that I do it but Dan Kathy you
know what chick-fil-a if you want to
apologize for something don't apologize
for racism but you could apologize for
your waffle fries because let's be
honest about that your waffle fries are
bad
certainly overrated I would call them
outright bad most of the time and I
think it's time we have an honest
conversation about chick-fil-a yes their
chicken sandwich the number one on the
value meal is good that's it they have
nothing else on the menu that's anything
to write home about their raps are
actually bad like stale and it's like
something you buy at a gas station
salads are okay but you get a salad just
as good at McDonald's or any other
fast-food place waffle fries are not
good undercooked underseasoned bland
flimsy flabby disgusting if I want great
fries I'll go to RB you get a curly
fries I go to Sonic get a get get tater
tots okay any of those options let me go
to McDonald's of their fries are better
then chick-fil-a that's the real point
here that's what we need to talk about
number three here's something that
happened in Southern California a mother
was attending a protest with her child
the child stopped breathing she screams
for help a cop rushes in as the footage
right now clears the child's airwaves
and saves his life now I you know you
see that you think okay if we'd to fund
the police or if there no police
who's running in to save the kid's life
call a social worker to come in who we
callin a lawyer somebody from the ACLU
they're gonna come save his life this is
what cops do all the time throughout the
country every day
maybe there's hundreds of examples
probably every single day of cops saving
somebody's life all that's going out the
window if we get rid of the cops number
for Amy Klobuchar is withdrawing her
name from the VP consideration saying
that a woman of color should be picked
instead here she is
you know Lawrence I have never as you
probably know on many many shows since I
endorsed the vice president and that
joyful night in Dallas
I've never commented on this process at
all but let me tell you this after what
I've seen in my state what I've seen
across the country this is a historic
moment and America must seize on this
moment and I truly believe as I actually
told the vice president last night when
I called him that I think this is a
moment to put a woman of color on that
ticket and there are so many incredible
we qualified women but if you want to
heal this nation right now my party yes
but our nation this is sure a hell of a
way to do it and that's just what I
think after being through this in my
state I am very inspired by that I find
that so inspiring that I'd like to
announce that I am also withdrawing from
consideration to be Joe Biden's VP so
that a woman of color can be picked
instead hashtag hero hashtag and racism
in fact I'm withdrawing from
consideration
I'll go step further I'll go for several
steps further okay I withdraw from
consideration to be VP
I also withdraw from consideration to be
a NASA astronaut to be a professor of
physics at Princeton to be a head chef
to be the quarterback of the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers I will not accept any of
those positions I'll tell you right now
I will not accept it I am withdrawing
from consideration don't even consider
me I'm not gonna take the job and I'll
tell you why a woman of color
needs to be in all those positions I
will cede my position which I don't have
to her you want to talk about heroism
there it was folks you're welcome
number five finally a report from The
Daily wire says Flyers passed among
members of the New York City Police
Department's NYPD are reportedly urging
officers to go on strike on July 4th the
New York Post reports that multiple cops
inform them that the Flyers are
retribution for police reform and a
perceived anti-cop climate following the
outrage over high-profile police
killings of unarmed black men across the
country one text message that has been
shared on police officers reads NYPD
cops will strike on July 4th to let the
city have their independence without
cops cops that say we can't strike
because of the Taylor law the people and
the city doesn't honor us why honor them
and then it goes on from there so I
don't know if this is actually gonna
happen or not but you hear reports of
this all across the country of cops that
are going on strike or will go and
strike and you know and I think they
should it is this is one area I'm not
I'm not always in favor of or impressed
by strikes but in this case yeah I think
that if there was ever a time if there
was ever a time for a group of people to
go on strike I think this is it and I
hope they do it we're gonna get to our
daily cancellation in just a second
before we do if you're not a daily wire
member you should consider getting a
reader's pass to daily wire comm it's a
great value for only three dollars a
month and when you sign up you get that
first month for only 99 cents and the
thing is you know there's a lot of
leftist spin and you know there's
there's a lot going on in the news it's
hard to know exactly what to think of
all these things and what the truth is
and that's why you need a daily wire
pass if you one of the one of the
articles for example that you could read
if you get a reader's pass is article I
just wrote last week called it's time to
face the facts we cannot be United kind
of a depressing article we've talked
about it on this show the fact that I
think unity is impossible in America at
this point and we are headed for
some kind of fracturing or break I think
that's almost inevitable at this point
but I make my case for that in that
article if you get a reader's pass you
can read that and go to daily wire calm
right now and sign up all right today
for our daily cancellation I'm canceling
the mayor of Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf
thick as I pronounced it some background
here a few days ago somebody was walking
through a park at Oakland they found
some rope hanging in a tree which they
interpreted immediately as a noose and
as a hate crime here's the footage of
that you could you could sort of barely
see some rope there that's actually not
a noose but it is a rope with like a
little loop at the end it doesn't really
look like a noose to me at all I see
that and I think of the context it's in
a park the first thing I'm going to
think is that that was there for someone
there's probably something connected to
that and it was there as a swing or some
sort of activity you know there was
people were climbing the tree with it
that looks exactly like the sort of
thing I see in a tree trees around my
house look where my kids will put put
you know ropes and stuff in trees so
they can climb they can make swings and
all kinds of different things that would
be my first assumption and what do you
know that's exactly what it is a guy
named Victor a black man put the rope
there for kids to play on there used to
be a whole swing system for exercising
and for playing and and he put it up
there and in fact here he is on camera
explaining that he put it there and why
he put it there
thousands of people so there you go
there's nothing here there's no hate
crime nothing it is a hundred percent
confirmed with zero doubt that is this
is not a hate crime it's a completely
innocent and even friendly act by a
black man who was on camera saying not a
hate crime folks I just put it there for
you no you're wildly misinterpreting
this so let's all move on can we move on
no apparently we can't the patrols will
start around the clock here at Lake
Merritt starting tonight until Sunday
organizers say they want to create a
presence to ensure safety
we can organize ourselves to take care
of ourselves that's what's happening
tonight at Oakland's Lake Merritt a
group called community ready Corps is
taking to the streets three to five
nurses that have been found hanging
around the lake folks can't quite
identify where they come from and who
did it it all started Tuesday when
someone spotted what appears to be a
noose tied to a tree branch on the Grand
Avenue side of the lake a facebook video
of that rope with the hashtag end racism
went viral Mayor Libby Schaaf is
condemning what she calls symbols of
hate these symbols are symbols of racial
violence and it's incumbent on all of us
to have that sensitivity to have that
knowledge
the mayor says even though there are
claims the ropes aren't nooses and were
used for exercise equipment that doesn't
excuse the person who put them there she
is calling for a hate crime
investigation
a man shared this video with us telling
us the ropes have been there for months
and there was no
malicious intent behind them that's not
how the public feels about it tonight
especially after two men found hanging
from trees in Southern California were
ruled suicides and are now being
investigated for a noose to show up on
on Monday morning after two black lives
matters events just seems far too
coincidental and for those who are
patrolling it is not acceptable
we have to transition into systems of
Community Safety in Oakland Sheryl heard
NBC Bay Area news yes it is a hundred
percent confirmed that this is not a
hate crime but that's not how the public
feels about it they don't feel that way
that's not how they feel their feelings
are wrong they were they were wrong and
how they felt they felt a certain way
they interpret it a certain way they're
just wrong that's it you're just wrong
people are wrong all the time and this
is one of those times so you're wrong
stop being wrong I don't know what to
tell you but the feelings no the feeling
is what matters not the fact not the
reality so they're gonna they're gonna
go on patrols they're going on it
they're setting up patrols because of a
swing in a tree is they did they say
they're doing over night patrols I don't
know if I I wasn't really I was too
depressed to pay very close attention
are they are they setting up like
overnights sentries on the border it
then you know the one person says it's
not it's not a coincidence that these
ropes showed up after a black lives
matter protest
well you're right it's not because they
didn't show up after the protest they've
been there for months it's just that you
just noticed it but the truth doesn't
matter the truth doesn't matter at all
anymore it makes no difference here's
the mayor doing a press conference about
the swing and keep in mind as you listen
to this she knows that it's a swing and
this is what she said the Oakland Police
Department has turned over the evidence
to the FBI we have to start with the
assumption that these are hate crimes
we cannot take these actions lately
these symbols are symbols of racial
violence and it's incumbent on all of us
to have that sensitivity to have that
knowledge and that is why I've directed
our staff to remove any such symbol of
hatred regardless of the intention of
what put it there what a privilege for
those of us that don't feel complete
fear and terror when we see a rope in
the tree that is a privilege that so
many of our African American residents
do not enjoy but you see an overwhelming
amount of of anguish of rage of fatigue
of grief and yes the fact that we had an
extremist charged with the murder of
Patrick underwood an extremist group the
boogaloos that is trying to ferment a
race war we have to see this moment for
what it is a reckoning and in Oakland we
cannot further terrorized or traumatize
our black residents and yes the
incidents of the last few weeks but
frankly of the last few centuries is the
backdrop upon which we have to make
these decisions today
enough is enough and again the
intentions do not matter because the
harm is real first of all I want to note
for the record that she did say that
extremists are trying to ferment hate I
don't think I misheard that she did say
ferment didn't she so they're putting
hate in like a big barrel and they're
letting it ferment for a few days to get
that alcohol content and then they're
bottling it selling it like moonshine on
the street fermented Haight delicious
but of course I shouldn't be surprised
that this woman doesn't know the
difference between foment and ferment
because she is of course profoundly
deeply impressively stupid notice at the
beginning she says we have to start with
the assumption that it's a hate crime
those were her actual words start we
have to start with your subject that's a
crime no no we don't no matter you see
that's exactly the opposite of what we
have to do
that's not no when something happens you
don't come in and say okay everybody
calm down calm down let's just begin
with the assumption that your worst
possible interpretation of this event is
correct let's begin with that okay in
order to clarify things imagine in your
head what is the worst possible
explanation and just assume that it's
true no that's not what you do and in
this particular case when it comes to
assumptions the assumptions should be
that it's therefore a swing that should
be your assumption to begin with because
all you have to do all you have to do is
count how many swings are hanging in
parks versus how many racist nooses are
hanging in parts and I think that the
ratio is probably something like 80
billion to 1 approximately which means
that your assumption should be that it's
a swing until evidence to the contrary
emerges that in this case evidence for
the swing emerged evidence in the form
of a black man saying yep its first wing
I put it up and then this white woman
goes on about what a privilege it is for
people who aren't traumatized by ropes
a black man put it there you're saying
that what he's he's he's privileged
you're saying that the black man put a
swing up for kids because of his
privilege what are you babbling about
and of course the the coup de coeur uh
the coup de Gras at the end where she
says intentions don't matter its
intentions don't matter
yes Libby and I love that her name is
actually Libby
by the way Libby the Lib yes Libby
intentions do matter they're all that
matter actually when it comes to a hate
crime the only thing that matters is the
intention that's that's how you judge if
a hate crimes being committed it or not
when it comes to a person's actions yeah
and when it comes to an action a
statement and event that can be
interpreted in multiple ways the only
deciding factor is intention if somebody
does something and you're not sure how
to interpret it what you do is you go to
them and say why did you do that and
then they'll tell you and they'll say oh
I did it because of this and that's it
now if they tell you that oh I did it
because it's a you know I I'm trying to
I'm a racist I'm a Klan member we kind
of be kind of odd for that particular
gentleman to say that but you know
because they don't thing is like if if
there's a racist group out there that
are planting nooses and trees they they
would I imagine the terrorists okay
terrorists want you to when they commit
an act of terrorism they want you to
know that it was terrorism and they're
gonna claim credibility credit for it
because that's the whole point they're
trying to terrorize you and so someone
for a racist reason put a noose in a
tree that to terrorize the community and
then someone else comes along and claims
credit for it and says it was just a
swing well then the person who put it
there is going to come out and say no no
no my point was to tear
Rize you here's no that's whether that's
so be terrorized any words to that
effect will be communicated so that's
why when it comes to intention
attentions do matter number one and in
order to know the intention you have to
ask someone and when they tell you all
you can do is just take them at their
word that's all you can do if I say
something and you're not sure how to
interpret it it sounds like it could be
horrible or maybe you could go at all
you could do is say to me Matt why did
you say that you know I'll gladly tell
you this is why I said it this is what I
was trying to communicate it doesn't
make any sense for you to then say you
claim that's what you meant but I feel
like you meant this other thing over
here so I'm just gonna assume that
that's what you actually meant what now
you're a better authority on what was in
my head than I am there when it comes to
actions and intentions there is only one
authority on earth there is only one
person on earth who is an authority and
an absolute authority on that subject
and that is the doer or the Sailor the
doer of the deed or the Sailor of the
words that is the oh that is the one
absolute authority on planet earth on
that subject the only person who could
speak to their own intentions is the
individual themselves and once you hear
them explain it all you can do as a
thinking person is just accepted but
again I mean I here I am trying to be
reasonable and explain and give
arguments and everything and it doesn't
matter because we're way past the point
of explanation or logic or rationality
and this is just blind hysteria and
that's why the mayor of Oakland is
cancelled like so many other mayors
across the country are canceled and
really have just canceled themselves I
guess by stepping back and letting
Anarchy take over their streets so maybe
it's a little bit redundant to cancel
them we'll leave it there have a great
day everybody have a great weekend we'll
talk on Monday Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we
will get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there